si on s'adresse quand même monsieur le
premier ministre la vie continue il n'y
a aucune raison mise à part pour les
populations fragilisées de modifier nos
habitudes de sortie cette phrase à un
mois quasiment jour pour jour est allée
du président de la république emmanuel
macron à propos de la crise du colis de
19 en une phrase voilà résumé tout
l'impréparation et l'incompétence de
l'état
mais ce n'est pas une surprise depuis
nos compatriotes découvrez subissent la
litanie de vos mensonges car vous avez
menti et vous saviez vous saviez depuis
le 11 janvier quand agnès buzyn a
prévenu le président de la république et
l'ensemble de votre gouvernement vous
saviez et vous avez choisi de mentir
vous avez mentir les français sont morts
le 18 février le ministre de la santé
olivier ferrand déclaré que la france
était prête
le 26 février jérôme salomon directeur
général de la santé a dit qu'il n'y
avait pas de sujet de pénurie concernant
les masques 20 mars
c'est laurent nunez qui a refusé de
reconnaître le manque de masques mais
alors pourquoi jérôme salomon at il
affirmé en privé quatre jours plus tôt
je le cite les stocks de masques sont
limitées et on en cherche partout
pourquoi le 5 avril christophe castaner
a appelé les français à donner leur
masque aux hôpitaux
vous avez vous même monsieur le premier
ministre affirmé le 13 mars que porter
un masque ne servait à rien la réalité
c'est que vous avez menti sur les
masques pour gagner du temps
sachant pertinemment que les stocks
stratégiques avaient disparu depuis des
années et que donc la france n'avait
plus conséquence aujourd'hui la préfète
de la région grand-est réquisitionne les
6 millions de masques destinés aux
personnels soignants des
bouches-du-rhône et vous avait
réquisitionné les 4 millions de masques
commandés par la région bourgogne
franche comté
cela vire à l'anarchie vous avez même
réussi à faire voler en éclats l'unité
nationale incapable de prévoir vous êtes
incapable de protéger la population et
si les français sont en réanimation
n'en déplaise aux sinistres préfet de
police de paris c'est parce que votre
gouvernement n'a pas su pas pu ou pas
voulu les protéger tous ses drames vous
êtes vous en étaient responsables
et peut-être demain serez vous reconnu
coupable alors ma question la voici
pensez vous monsieur le premier ministre
que vos mensonges successifs relève de
la cour de justice de la république va
vous répondre la parole est à monsieur
verrons je rappelle que ici la parole
est libre mais la mesure fait aussi
partie de la tradition du cdah
monsieur le sénateur aviez vous poser
une question à laquelle nous sommes les
derniers à pouvoir répondre
par contre j'ai une question à vous
poser
mme suire aviez pensé vous demander ma
démission comme ministre des solidarités
la santé comme madame marine le pen
avait demandé la démission de madame
roselyne bachelot alors ministre de la
santé parce qu'elle avait commandé je
cite trop de masques je vous remercie
merci je vais maintenant levé la séance
merci monsieur le premier ministre